quand les grenouilles grosse fait du
beau temps à chaque fois qu'il ya les
mouettes qui passe au dessus de ville
l'a régulièrement le lendemain il peut
pour le beau temps pour que les
hirondelles le volvo si la saint médard
ils flottent encore 40 jours plus tard à
moins que saint barnabé lui coupe
l'herbe sous le pied me tende disait
toujours que quand elle voyait landes
abraham au travers des rivières c'était
la pluie avant trois jours tout à
l'heure quand vous allez voir le soleil
a lieu ce coup je suis venu avec le
regarder dans les fenêtres qui sait
rouge là dans les réseaux comme il y
aurait dû faire dans nos maisons
kamissoko chaleur on accuse d'avoir du
beau temps dans le ciel rose le soir par
exemple qui fera du vent le lendemain
quand mon petit chat se grattent les
oreilles c'est qu'il va plus vers le
lendemain on lui parle comme si l'air
comme on dit dans ces files est très
méchant ils veulent faire un trait les
vaches pour la coller je veux faire de
l'orage